hey everybody
welcome to an earlier than normal live
stream we actually have
um multiple streams uh today
scheduled in fact and i'm going to tell
you about those
in a moment i want to make sure all
of my graphics are working yes they seem
to be um
so here's what's going on we're going to
talk about a lot of different things
today we're keeping an eye on three
different streams
this was a haphazard early morning press
briefing this is typically not the time
when these
press briefings happen i have a sense of
why they're doing it early and i'm going
to talk to you about that
um in a moment i will answer super chats
via youtube and messages that come along
with subscriptions over on twitch as we
wait
uh for the start of this and of course
um i mean so so last night i had a
stream with eric rosen
and i mentioned this is not about that
but of course we know about
the the just tragedy of the passing of
fellow progressive host michael brooks
and i said i would be discussing it
today
and um i did we we've already recorded
today's podcast and youtube clips
and i talk about really just the whole
story with michael brooks so
we're meeting him 10 years ago and and
him saying he's interested in getting
into what i'm doing and knowing
sam cedar is always looking for good
people and introducing him to sam
cedar and you know the rest is history
from that point forward
most of you guys uh know the the the the
trajectory
um that took place there i see uh
leftist best matthew sending a super
chat saying rest in peace michael brooks
yes indeed
um so i'm glad to talk about that to the
extent people
you know have questions or whatnot but
i've recorded like a
a segment about that already it's going
to be on our podcast today which drops
at 3 pm eastern
um and um i'll you know the clip will be
out later and all of that um
majority report putting out a statement
about it yesterday and of course you
know before these things go public
the text messages and the phone calls
are flying and i
had the i mean listen it's one of these
things is about falling out of touch
with people
we've all been kind of in our own
bubbles during coronavirus in the last
24 hours
tragically as a result of what happened
with michael brooks
i talked to kyle kolinsky who i hadn't
talked to in a while
i talked to benjamin dixon i was in
touch with farron
cousins from ring of fire i was in touch
with sam
cedar obviously i was in touch with you
know a lot of the behind the scenes
people that you may not know from
watching these shows but who are friends
of mine
and you know my takeaway is let's let's
not fall out of touch with people
um and i'm going to talk more about so
so just i feel like it's important
because everybody is so
so focused on it as we should be i'm not
ignoring the topic of michael brooks
we talked about it yesterday today on
the show and i'm glad to talk about it
here as well but today's event is this
kaylee mckennony press briefing
scheduled for the top of the hour
and so today is an insane day because
we've already filmed today's show
for the podcast on youtube i'm doing
this stream now as we approach 11am here
on the east coast
at 5 00 p.m today eastern i'm going to
be back with another stream but that's
not even the last stream today this is
what's crazy
at 5 p.m today donald trump is
restarting
the daily coronavirus press briefings or
semi-daily
and this clearly is out of panic
now i have a segment today on the show
called a desperate trump
is a dangerous trump and donald trump is
increasingly
desperate because he's losing in the
polls and thus
that is going to represent a lot of
danger now the other day
kelly kellyanne conway said the reason
trump's polling is down is because he's
not doing daily press briefings
the daily press briefings are what
started this problem where he talked
about injecting bleach and isopropyl
so i don't think trump restarting these
press briefings is going to help his
poll numbers
but needless to say it is clearly an act
of desperation
and they are restarting today so i'm
going to be back
probably about 4 30 p.m eastern with
that
press briefing and then tonight
as you know i have been announced as a
participant in the chess.com
pog champs 2 tournament and
last week i had a lesson with one of my
coaches levy rosman
i'm being informally advised by
international master eric rosen and we
had a stream last night
and tonight i will be streaming with my
second official coach alexandra botez
and that's going to be tonight i don't
even know when we were originally going
to do it at 6 p.m eastern but now with
the trump
press briefing back we're probably
pushing it back
uh alexander said just to text her when
i'm sort of ready to go so this is the
first of
three streams today plus the show so
this may actually be the day on which we
do
more content than on any other single
day that we've done
really since the um really since the
impeachment
hearings now let me just ban some people
i'm seeing
trolling as well as anti-semitism and
just mean-spirited comments both in
youtube and twitch so we're going to
drop the ban hammer on a bunch of people
um and you know people are asking about
daily schedule like schreis
is asking about this i never do a daily
schedule every day is so
different um so no we're going to be
taking it day by day but today
i'm here now we've got an hour podcast
coming out and clips
and then of course we will also have uh
the press briefing at five
and then my stream with alexandra boats
has later on in the day
so a lot um certainly going on now
listen in the meantime
coronavirus continues to rage i don't i
don't know you know half the country
seems to not be paying attention to it
anymore
um but yesterday we had another 63 000
cases now importantly
you know there's people who said oh
david yesterday deaths were down to 546.
understand that deaths are always down
on monday because of reporting
and in fact it was the worst monday in a
long time
so yesterday 5 45. if you look at monday
the 13th
465 if you look at monday the 6th
378 if you look at monday the
what was it the 30th uh or no 29th
or maybe it was the 28th 285 so the
point is if you just compare mondays
we've been having worsening mondays
where you you have less data from the
weekend
and that pattern had gone all the way
down
to about the beginning of july and now
every week we are seeing more and more
total cases sometimes looking at a
three-day moving average is useful
and you see that the peaks are starting
to climb
and then you have your seven-day moving
average which shows us that from around
july 6
it's been sort of straight up now
fortunately we
we do still have some states that are
doing well and again i'm not bragging
about
massachusetts but i'm just you know this
is part of a package of states that has
been staying
under 300 cases a day and that's a
really good thing
and listen really tuesday wednesday
thursday friday are the days where we
get the most extensive data
so you know is today as a tuesday going
to be worse than last tuesday
versus the previous tuesday that's sort
of what we're going to be paying
attention to
and we'll know you know in seven hours
or something like that
i see some super chats coming in i also
see people signing up over on twitch i
want to say thanks to
laser angel who has subscribed and sends
the message
rest in peace michael brooks yes indeed
simple zack has subscribed with prime
and says always enjoy your live streams
keep them coming
and wafer has also subscribed with prime
which i appreciate over on youtube
leica says no message just love and
support to the david pakman show friends
and family stay safe everyone stay safe
everyone yeah good message
mark fillion says i bet kaylee is going
to announce when the army will take over
the country
immanuel kant says hey david toby hear
love from frankfurt
germany bolo turner says i found sam
cedar and michael brooks shortly after
finding your show years ago while i
didn't know him personally it hurts to
know a person
who was a force of good is gone rise
in power mr brooks yeah and if you're
just joining us we're not ignoring the
michael
brooks topic i've already recorded um
i hate to call it a sort of eulogy in a
sense
uh and it'll be on today's podcast and
it'll be on today's youtube channel and
it is a tragedy
it is a tragedy samuel lopez
says david uh argentina
i don't really this is about my favorite
argentinian boxer i unfo i'm not a
boxing fan so i couldn't tell you my
favorite american boxer argentinian
boxer
or any of it sean m
says david how often do you receive
amorous dms or emails from adoring fans
do you disclose the nature of these
messages to your girlfriend
that's a little bit private that's
that's very very private i don't know
that i can really go into that
azeem abu khalil says rest in peace
michael brooks despite my very
conflicted feelings on the guy
he seemed to be a genuinely nice person
who touched the lives of so many
yeah listen i mean i i didn't agree with
michael brooks on a lot of political
things and that's fine i think the idea
though
is um that as he
saw it his priority was to improve uh
improve life for people through activism
and even if we didn't see eye to eye on
every individual issue it's really a
loss
for the community um and i think that
that's the most important thing
i can say i'm i'm expanding on this
later of course
on the right on the regular show uh
blake
yeah steaky blakey eats steaky
okay has subscribed with prime over on
twitch
which i very much appreciate um
if you've been missing my chess lesson
streams on twitch
make sure to um
follow at twitch.tv slash
david pakman very very important stuff
we are here just standing by for kaylee
mckennany
this was an again one of these abruptly
11 scheduled 11 a.m
quick we've got to do an 11 a.m press
briefing we have things to tell you
i assume she'll come out and give us 90
seconds of bs
before uh not answering questions
then i will be back at roughly 4 30 p.m
eastern
this evening afternoon for the trump
coronavirus press briefing which is
restarting today
and then i will be back even later with
a third stream for the day
with alexandra botez continuing my chess
training
for pog champs 2 and right on cue
we have an incoming hype train over on
twitch
where we have we have failed to hit
level five a couple of times but
jakugetti has subscribed with the
message
thanks for doing what you do enjoy the
show
thank you i appreciate that support
crypto monkey says your australian
allies a way to return to sanity in the
usa
in november love from down under thank
you
and ciro 3385 says thoughts on trump's
recent patriotic mask wearing tweet
it's desperation this is desperation so
you know an
ounce of prevention is worth a pound of
cure properly dealing with coronavirus
from day one
would have not would have avoided trump
being in the desperate position he's in
now where he's losing by anywhere from
three according to right wing pollster
rasmussen up to 15
according to multiple other polls now
trump has to go crazy
talking about the mask as patriotic now
trump has to restart daily coronavirus
press briefings which
i believe hurt him more than they helped
so it's all desperation
trump is cornered and desperate and i
have a piece today
about um what the dangers are
of of an increasingly cornered donald
trump
as we wait for today's press briefing
jamal swift says hey homie how's life
otherwise hanging in there jamal great
to see you jamal's been around the
streams for a long time
always great to uh always great to see
him yeah i mean you know it's uh
it's day at a time right now a lot of a
lot of things happening 2020 has not
really been like
the best year so far i think a lot of us
would probably
agree with that and you know even though
this is one of those things where it's
like
my show is doing great and and obviously
i'm glad for that it's growing faster
than it has in a long time and that's
great but
there's so much suffering going on uh
you know we lost
michael brooks yesterday tragically um
close to a thousand people a day on
average or dying again from coronavirus
um you know a lot of bad things are
going on and we're
my goal is that i'm having a horizon of
let's start to turn it around
in november um
i don't know people are asking if
there's any stream that's in the room
right now
i would imagine one of these two fox or
usa today would go live as soon as
there's action in the room so to speak
but if anybody knows of one that is
already live in the room by all means
let me know
maddie i says hey david what do you like
about gardening p.s i didn't always
agree with michael brooks but he was as
honest and authentic
as they come very sad well said yeah i
mean i just like gardening because it's
the exact opposite of what
my work is same reason i like chess you
know it's just a completely different
framework in which uh to operate and
something totally different to
um learn and and understand so it's good
to get a break from from politics
every once in a while uh i don't expect
that this is going to be a particularly
long press briefing partially because
donald trump also has on his schedule
at 12 15 pm eastern which is in just a
little over an hour
signing a memorandum and my guess is
that this press briefing is to urgently
tell us
what is going to be in that memorandum
but we will soon see and we will learn
very much about it i'm sure i do want to
say
thank you to um
l o donohue who has just grabbed a
membership
at joinpackman.com and is new member
number
one today at joinpackman.com few other
super chats coming in
javi rodriguez says it was heartbreaking
to see the majority report crew find out
about michael
on air and have to end the show early he
was so smart and funny and he will be
missed yes haunting i would call that
video clip from sam's show yesterday
kennel shaw says need my daily dose of
dp
oh my goodness matt chavez says will you
be touching on the false notion that
people with pre-existing conditions who
die
shouldn't be counted or aren't serious
in an upcoming segment
no i've already talked about that i mean
listen you know i even have some friends
who are on youtube
sharing stuff like someone died in a car
crash and they tested positive for
coronavirus
and they are they were considered a
coronavirus death
listen you know here's the reality um
we can tell the difference between
normal people can tell the difference
between what should count as a
coronavirus death and what should not
if you have diabetes which is known to
be an aggravating condition for
coronavirus and you get coronavirus and
you get put on a ventilator and you die
that's a coronavirus death if you die in
a car accident
and were asymptomatic and later test
positive for coronavirus
that doesn't seem to me like it gets at
the heart of what a coronavirus death
is and i think most of us can
understand the difference between
between those
mike valverde says how is the blue wave
looking for taking over congress in 2020
well we the the democrats have the house
i don't know if you mean the senate
if you mean the senate i have a bunch of
clips about that you can look at
seth barham says david how urgent is
this briefing on a scale of one to
defcon 5.
this briefing is so urgent that oan is
going to get to ask a question
let me put it that way nick xrp
de la paz sensei or has signed up at the
soyboy level
ognin slovkovsky says hey david i'm
increasingly worried if biden wins about
a possible
competent trump-like protectionist
winning in 2024
i don't think the democrats have learned
from 2016. let's take it a step at a
time
let's take it a step at a time rakhim
says david love the show keep
independent media alive
janelle says does covering the news ever
give you anxiety and if so how do you
manage it well
i have scheduled breaks so basically i'm
increasingly going in the direction of
monday through thursday or when i'm like
in deep in politics
and then friday i'm basically doing the
business stuff
for the show which is really not super
political
and then weekends i try to tune out all
together so so basically my goal is
three out of seven days i'm not even
following politics
now you know then i go and talk to my
mom on saturday and she wants to talk
about politics and i don't
uh and that's uh you know that's a whole
scene which i've described to some
before
but that's a story maybe for a different
day
hi mom if you're watching of course um
we are five minutes past the scheduled
start time for today's press briefing
does anybody know if anybody is live
in the room right now like sometimes
washington post is live in the room or
sometimes it's now this
i didn't find anybody that was live in
the room but i'm uh
nobody seems to now everybody seems to
say there is nobody
with a live shot of the room right now
no one i've seen is live yet so
that's not a good sign global is live in
the i don't know what global is let's
see global
kaylee maga nanny
um yeah i'm not seeing it here's a
bloomberg video let me see if bloomberg
might be live in the room
but i am not seeing that c-span has the
room
okay let's see that
c-span here we go
i'm just verifying it before i put a
whole bunch of stuff on screen
um past live streams
i don't even see a c-span live stream at
all right now
unfortunately two weeks ago three weeks
ago
c-span mckennony
let's see yeah i can't even find that
live stream
unfortunately so that's not uh that's
not working for me now this news okay
let's try that
now this press briefing
live now
all right here we go i'm hoping you guys
are going to come through for me oh
we've got an ad
we've got an ad hold on a second we will
watch that jared hunter asks will oan
give trump his own show if he is voted
out
sure why not
they are live on youtube it's all
youtube this is
we're all watching youtube here uh okay
ah very good
all right so it seems like things are
getting closer nobody else yet very good
so we'll stick with now this
for now or now news or whatever it is
that they're called very good standing
by for the start of this
press briefing other super chats coming
in
michael blanco says important to
remember that if another country
develops a vaccine trump will
try to take credit for it to fool voters
and many will be tricked
i have a story that i'm planning for
friday
where i am going to talk about what
could turn polling around for trump
and somebody else doing something on
coronavirus and trump taking credit for
it is certainly something he's going to
try no doubt about it whatsoever
um leftist best matthew says michael
brooks introduced a lot of people to an
alternative to capitalism will you ever
bring people like richard wolf on now
i've interviewed richard wolff it must
be 15 or 20 times he was my professor at
the university of massachusetts
always glad for professor brooks wolf
rather to be on and yes he was a
frequent guest with
michael brooks crazy hawaiian
signs up on twitch and says thanks for
the company during the crazy lockdown
of course tpd says hey david what bad
movie do you like as a guilty pleasure
blue chips with shaquille o'neal that
may not even be a bad movie honestly i
think it's actually a pretty solid movie
i have to tell you
neutral music says david if you were
part of biden's team would you advocate
for skipping the debates until trump's
taxes or release seems to be fair on
some level
uh listen no not in those terms but i
don't think
i don't care about conventions or
debates like at this point if neither
happens
i don't care november is so clear to me
that it doesn't make any difference to
me thanks to kenny redmond who's new
member number two today
and candy martinez who's new member
number three also
philly felix philly felix is new member
number four
i will just very briefly mention i've
been doing this only once per stream
lately
and people the support has just been
outpouring
all of the stuff we do like three
streams today plus the podcast the
youtube channel all this stuff
it's mostly supported by website
memberships you know all these different
platforms they're
they're taking taking slices of support
on our website joinpakman.com
whenever everybody's whenever you sign
up we just pay 2.9 percent
to swipe credit and debit cards and we
keep the rest it's the most direct way
to support us
early this month several hundred people
canceled their memberships
because of what's going on with the
virus and
we've been trying to dig out from that
and we've done a great job of of
starting to do that
so if you are in the boat where
a dollar fifty or two bucks a month is
okay for you consider grabbing a
membership at joinpakman.com and i'll
even give you a better coupon code 2020
now is a beautiful coupon code powerful
coupon code
july surprise all lowercase
all one word okay it's an even
crazier i can't say it because right
these southern governors like ron
desantis these crazy guys
they're failing on coronavirus but they
would come after me for a discount this
big so i'm not even going to tell you
what the discount is
but july surprise as a discount code off
of any membership at joinpacman.com
is like it's unprecedented it's like
nothing anybody has ever even conceived
of before
uh to quote donald trump but in all
seriousness
if you sign up on my website i will give
you a beautiful thank you
during the stream and i really in all in
all seriousness all joking aside the
coupon code is not illegal in florida or
in any state
i so appreciate folks who have been uh
signing up and supporting over
over the last several weeks if you're
just joining us we are now
11 minutes late for kaylee mcinanny
i have no problem with my earpiece here
kaylee mcinanny
um i guess announcing what it is that
donald trump is going to be signing in
about an hour that would be my guess
as to why they are holding this earlier
than normal
press briefing uh and we we will soon
find out about that huge thank you to
joseph rader for
gifting five subs over on twitch
we are trying to sort of build our way
back up on twitch subs
our vacation definitely uh put a bit of
a damper on that but we are working on
it
i want to address some of these other
super chats
that are coming in um
let's see walter says hey david any
thoughts on trump saying the supreme
court
daca decision gives him more power i
think he's an idiot and he has no idea
what he's talking about
dev rod says talking about if kovid has
a one percent death rate or a 0.4
percent death rate is useless we will
never know the true number
for example too many remote villages
around the world where people won't be
tested if they die
yeah so i did a story yesterday about
deaths per capita versus the case
fatality rate versus the infection
fatality rate
each one is useful for different things
but
the best tool we have for comparing how
one country is doing to another
is deaths per capita because you need
only know the country's population
you don't need to know the testing level
or the level of asymptomatic contagion
and so
trump is trying to use the case fatality
rate when in reality the right metric
for what he's talking about
is deaths per capita and that's not so
good
if you look at deaths per capita you
will see
deaths per million you will see that the
us is 10th
in deaths per million and we are getting
very close to chile
which would put us into ninth for deaths
per million
and you know san marino and andorra are
so
small that they arguably shouldn't be
even included
and so really we are now uh eighth
and are close to going into seventh if
we pass chile
which me we may well do um in in
upcoming days
um stuart keating asks do i prefer to
play the sicilian or the scandinavian oh
i'm not going to reveal any of my
preferences because i am in training for
a tournament and i wouldn't want to give
my opponents
any any any any advantage we've got a
bunch of people signing up for
membership and i want to thank some of
them we've got
zachary johnson who's number five today
kimberly mcdonald is number six
um gregory gettleson is new member
number seven on my website
iris noble is new member number eight
william rhodewald
number nine thanks for the for the
membership
jonathan lippilus is new member number
10.
josh napier is number 11. great to see
you josh
christopher shipman is new member number
12.
also can't forget sean mccloskey at
number 13
paul roger at number 14
richard wright and dan labono get us to
16
and then i of course would be remiss not
to mention andrew stryker new member
number 17
pear new burger i believe that is the
fourth member we have named pear
and uh liz curry
and jake johnson gets us to 20 wow
wow many things happening here that is
stunning unbelievable
okay um toby off
says thanks so much for your work david
i watch every video and want to throw
extra support your way keep it up thank
you i appreciate that
uh jen twitters says who do you find
more loathsome
sarah huckabee or kaylee magga nanny
equally i guess
equally i guess zachary foster do you
see the oxford vaccine as trump's hail
mary before he hopefully gets voted out
well
yeah the crazy thing is trump's hail
mary
is nothing that has to anything to do
with him in other words trump's hoping
for a treatment
or a vaccine which will have nothing to
do with him
to give him something to take credit for
and unfortunately
because so many of his followers are
incompetent they're going to fall for it
and that's a really sad thing
let me say thanks to benihas22 for the
twitch prime sub
tark97 for the tier 1 subscription
and harley girl one a harley girl 40 has
also subscribed with twitch prime the
coupon code only works on my website
the coupon code does not work on twitch
i see people
saying they're unable to find where on
twitch you put the coupon code it
doesn't go
on uh coupon code uh on twitch it goes
on my website um a lot of crazy things
are going on here
yeah geez as far as we know we are still
scheduled for
16 minutes ago we now have multiple
streams live in the room i think we can
start
pinching off some of these streams and
my preference
is the white house feed so we will go up
on volume there i do want to make sure
all of my audio properties are connected
oh they are not
very good so now there we go
good we're ready to go and we are
standing by for this
stream remember if you are just joining
me on
youtube um i would love it
in uh if you would just hit that like
and subscribe button
on youtube it's free and it really does
a lot for us
and our subscriptions have been off the
charts we're at
888 000 and likewise
um we are oh here we go let's see what's
going on
[Music]
hello everybody good morning everyone
by any objective standard the violence
chaos and anarchy in portland is
unacceptable democrats continue to put
politics above peace while this
president seeks to restore
law and order governor kate brown
a democrat governor of oregon said that
the president should quote stop playing
politics called law enforcement officers
secret police and likened it to
quote a dictatorship the governor also
called on the president to get his
officers
off the streets democrat mayor of
portland todd wheeler said the president
is trying to look strong for his base
while you had democrats on the hill
nancy pelosi calling these officers
storm troopers and jim clyburn calling
them
the gestapo so real quick this is they
want to create confrontations to then
make the left seem dangerous to take
attention away from failed coronavirus
and economic leadership that's the
strategy we predicted it it's happening
turner and the democrat
mayor are unwilling to admit that they
have lost control
of their city the well-organized mob in
portland has become increasingly
aggressive especially against law
enforcement officers
individuals have thrown bricks chunks of
concrete
glass bottles feces balloons filled with
paint
pig's feet slingshots to hurl ball
bearings
and batteries at federal agents and the
courthouse
multiple attempts to barricade officers
in the hatfield court
house have occurred attempts to start
the structure on fire as well
use of eyesight damaging laser devices
have been used in strobe lights against
federal agents as well
but according to speaker pelosi when
asked about the violence i'm telling you
they're going to keep deploying these
troops to create
violent confrontations to keep talking
about it and not the problems that
they've caused creatively to restore
law and order operation legend is a
great example of this
at the governor's request we went into
kansas city and surged the area with
federal
assets fbi dea atf and u.s marshals
this was named after legend talafero a
four-year-old
young boy who lost his life and was shot
in his bed tragically
this has been a successful operation
that has been
waged in his name including the arrest
of wanted fugitives
similarly president trump is taking
action in portland
portland even though you have a democrat
mayor and democrat governor unwilling to
work with us in this situation
we are surging resources along with
secretary wolf at dhs
and augmenting the federal protective
service to safeguard federal property
the bottom line is that this president
stands with law and order
which leads to peace and we will not
allow portland to become the new chop
like what we saw in seattle very much
wrong the presence of these uh no badge
troops
is actually making the violence worse
one the case of navy veteran christopher
david who went down because he said he
wanted to talk to the law enforcement
officers and ask them about the oath of
office
that they took uh he was as people saw
in videotape
he was beaten with a baton he had
pepper spray sprayed in his face he now
has two broken bones in his hand
is the president aware of what happened
to uh
to this navy veteran graduate of the
naval academy
and does he condone that kind of action
by these law enforcement officers
yeah i'm aware of the details of that
situation haven't heard the audio of the
video though i've seen it and i'd refer
you to dhs about the extenuating details
we always encourage the appropriate
uh use of force and we always also
encourage those in the area to
remain peaceful meaningless meaning my
second question is where
in the constitution does the president
derive
the authority to send federal law
enforcement officers to the streets of
american citizens
the will of the governmentals in those
cities
beautiful yes well what you're referring
to is portland and 40 u.s
code 1315 gives dhs the ability to
deputize officers in any department or
agency
like ice custom and border patrol and
secret service quote as
officers and agents they can be
deputized for the duty of uh in
connection with the protection of
property owned or occupied by the
federal government and persons on that
property
they have been beating the hell out of
people nowhere near federal property so
that's the way they're hiding behind it
there's
i think that that falls pretty well
within uh the limits of 40 u.s code 13.
it does not
that's a matter of protecting federal
property like federal courthouse in the
case of portland
does he see limitations to that power
how how much
how far does that power extend into the
streets of the city of portland how
you know what are their limitations on
that
authority to protect the federal
property under the law we believe that
agents can conduct investigations of
crimes committed against federal
property or federal officers and in the
case where you have someone shooting off
a commercial-grade firework
and then running across the street we
don't believe that that extends past our
jurisdiction
yeah really thank you yesterday the
president tweeted out an image of
himself
wearing a mask he said that wearing a
mask is an act of patriotism is more
patriotic than him hours later he was
spotted at the trump hotel
not wearing a mask why did it take him
so
long first of all six months in public
and why the mixed messaging
on this critical issue that his own top
health officials have said
is critical to fighting this pandemic
the president's always been consistent
on this
mask according to the cdc are
recommended but not required
he has said that he would wear one in
the case he couldn't appropriately
socially distance
um and he wore one and put up the
picture on twitter as you saw
does he think that it's important to
lead by example on this issue well the
president has led
he's been consistent even going back to
march 31st when he said yeah guys he led
he didn't wear a mask at all until this
weekend and then now that we have
nearly two million active cases now he's
wearing one out of desperation don't you
get it our mask in may the president
wore a mask at walter reed out of an
abundance of caution but as i've made
clear from this podium the president is
the most tested man in america he's
tested more than anyone multiple times a
day
doctor's shocked by his family
inappropriately let me ask you about the
federal students if i might negotiations
are ongoing why is the white house
blocking republicans requests for more
funding
for testing and contact tracing senator
roy blunt saying
it just doesn't make sense i think
that's just wrong
so no one is blocking any money from
testing
one of the things i would add is that
this is an ongoing negotiation we're
just in the early days of that
um currently and federal coffers we have
10 billion dollars that's with a b
unspent uh that is allocated for testing
and we want to ensure that in phase four
there is money
that is targeted in the way that makes
most sense
need that money is is the president
willing to have come to this
we're willing to put in money for
targeted testing that makes sense not
just dumping money
into a pot that already already contains
10 billion dollars
there's very little support in congress
for a payroll tax cut but the president
keeps pushing for it
why is that so important to him how does
a payroll tax that help
the 25 million americans out of work it
helps him actually make the case we have
to gut social security and medicare
that's why he wants it
unemployment benefits where as secretary
mnuchin said we want this to be
completed before
july 31st the date that that runs out we
don't want something to be an incentive
where
someone gets overpaid and has a
disincentive from going back to work
where they get paid more on unemployment
benefits than at work so we want to
be cautious about that while making sure
that those unemployed
are taken care of but the payroll tax in
particular
goes to some of our hardest working
americans the people that it benefits if
you look at the tax structure
i have an entire segment um debunking
this payroll tax holiday thing and it's
really important that everybody
understand this so check that clip out
on my youtube channel this is their
burden so it's a very smart policy those
are people who still have jobs so
wouldn't it be more important to focus
on the people who don't if you're
worried about the overall
cost of beautiful questions you can
focus on a number of things at once and
part of that's a payroll tax for middle
and income low income americans who are
out there working each and every day and
making their way through as best they
can it also means
unemployment benefits it also means
direct payments to americans so we're
looking at all of that and we would like
to see all of that
the second question on the briefing
today at five o'clock should we expect
to see members of the coronavirus task
force will dr
fauci will dr burks be there you'll have
to tune in to see
yes thank you tune in tonight on
portland i'm sending agents to portland
as well as
plans for chicago why are these the
right people
to send my understanding these agents
often work on
human smuggling drug trafficking things
like that do they have the right skill
set
whether it's gun violence in chicago or
squelling
these dhs officials are currently in
portland
portland protecting a courthouse we do
believe they're the right individuals
for that as does 40 usc 1315 the united
states code
um it's egregious what's happening the
frequency jammers the paladin air rifles
in portland it's being depicted as this
peaceful scene i can assure you
it's anything but that um where you've
had barricades
they're sending in federal coffers to
cough on people
the courthouse injury to a border patrol
team member's leg injuries to the head
shoulder and back of a deputy u.s
marshal
u.s marshal impaled his right hand on a
board filled with nails set out by the
protesters
this is not a peaceful scene i'm very
thankful to our u.s marshals
it's gotten dramatically less peaceful
since they sent in the federal troops
protecting a federal building um and
doing so at great cost to themselves
thanks i have two questions for you on
the stimulus first
um since you guys are committed to the
payroll tax cut that seems to be driving
up
the price tag of the whole package so is
the white house
view the one trillion dollar figure
that's been cited by gop leaders as a
hard cap are you willing to sign
something
that would spend not going to get in
front of these are all preliminary
discussions so you know i'll leave it to
the negotiators to decide the
uh trillion dollar number um was cited
by secretary mnuchin yesterday
but look this is the the beginning
stages we're looking at a number of
things but the president
was very clear that he would like to see
a payroll tax in there along with
liability protections
um tax credits for businesses to bring
people back to work and to have safety
he wants a ton of stuff that makes no
sense million dollars
for schools to reopen safely at least 70
billion and then on the testing
piece the one of the wait time the long
wait times that we're seeing for tests
around the country suggest that
we do need a massive influx of testing
beyond what's unspent
and that the federal government should
take more control of the here in
massachusetts we only have two to 300
cases a day
there's still a five to seven day delay
to get your test results a way that
it gets to the right people who need
testing at the right time not just
dumping money into a bucket so we want
more money we want it to be targeted
but i'm glad you brought up the timing
of the testing i talked to dr burks and
she's very encouraged by
the pool testing that's being can't be
trusted you can run
four to five times as many tests in the
same period of time
it by decreasing turnaround times at a
minimum of
uh by of two thirds so if you took three
days to get a test result
goes down to less than one if it took
six days goes down to less than two
and it's more labor intensive so they
would need to hire additional personnel
but cms is funding the test at about
four times the actual test costs
to ensure technicians and ppe
requirements can be met so
we are seeing encouraging signs sounds
like everything's great guys don't worry
just going back to the portland
situation what is sort of the policy
justification for federal officers not
identifying their agency and their
arrest authority when they
take a protester into this perfect
question so i've been told by dhs that
there is insignia
indicating that their law enforcement
they and the case you're referencing did
identify themselves to the individual
being obtained but that they don't
identify themselves to crowds because it
would put them at great risk and i think
you can see that as i noted when they're
sticking their hands into boards left
out by some of the writers
yes you know on june 16th
a little more than a month ago the white
house via the vice president
published an op-ed in the wall street
journal
the op-ed said that the media
has tried to scare the american people
about the chronovirus
he talked about low positivity rates and
declining case numbers
in half of the states
there have been 25 000 additional deaths
since that was published
does the white house still stand by that
op-ed and then just more generally
what happened here at the white house in
the administration in the last month
when the message was that this was a
problem
that was on the mend and being addressed
until now
with the exploding cases we've seen and
141 000
deaths well the white house has always
been very clear-eyed that as we reopened
we would see embers and in some cases
fires we've embers
and fires we are now at the peak like
the worst time is now
embers nine states um she does a lot of
extraordinary work
on that front so we've been clear-eyed
that as we reopen we would see
embers and sometimes fires but we're
encouraged that when you look at case
fatality for instance we're below the
european union
we're below the average of the war
remember case fatality just tells us
relative to testing what are the deaths
and that's not relevant we got to look
at deaths per capita we're 10th highest
in the world
two in testing in the world is india at
13.79 million
do you still see the main problem as the
op-ed pointed out as the
media trying to scare the american
people over coronavirus
i think in many cases the media has
tried to scare the american people i
think um there's a media page
a deficit in reporting about the cost of
staying shut down for instance when you
have
uh the fact that the american cancer
society saying that during the pandemic
we saw an 80
drop in cancer cases being identified
there are real costs
uh to a draconian extended shutdown and
you never
heard the other side of the health
equation those are real problems but you
can deal with that by saying
we're keeping abcd shut but right now
doctor's offices are places where you
should be going for screenings if you
have a symptom because we don't want to
be diagnosing things like you can deal
with that it's not just
we're shut down so cancer doesn't get
diagnosed or it's wide open
people yeah the president says he wants
to send these forces
to other cities like chicago
of cities that where the federal
property isn't necessarily under attack
what are they going to do when they get
to chicago
and these other cities with people and
unmarked events higher
shooting rates higher murder rates if
the president's worried about that
what are they going to do what are they
going to arrest people right i think
you're getting ahead of the president
here
he's he's made no announcements as to
who's going where he's very discouraged
by the violence that he's seen in
chicago it's why he sent
on a very strong letter to mayor
lightfoot offering help because she's
clearly unable to control her streets
and the governor as well unable to
control that area
um when you see the mere idea of a
problem
and trump swooping in to solve it is
antithetical to everything we know about
trump like
at the top level if there's a problem
and trump is proposed to be solving it
you should already be skeptical
missingry of chicago where 12 were
murdered this weekend
um 70 shot alone it's incredible what
we're seeing in chicago he's offered his
help and we encourage the mayor to take
it
and to be forthright about the situation
in her state much like
the governor of missouri was in working
with us on operation legend to protect
the people of missouri but the leaders
of these cities don't necessarily want
unmarked police
we've seen in portland with the premise
that they're protecting federal property
the leaders in these cities don't want
this sort of paramilitary police
they're offered the assistance of doj as
was done
where you've had fbi surge in the case
of operation legend
so when you have each weekend more than
a dozen people getting shot in your city
perhaps it's time more than a dozen
killed i should say and children perhaps
it's time to say
i need the help of the federal
government because what i'm doing is
simply not working
when more people are dying on the
streets of chicago than afghanistan and
iraq it's a tragedy what if they don't
say that yes
thank you well i have a question about
new york on a similar topic
yesterday uh president trump mentioned
the spike in violent crime in new york
and said quote
if the governor is not going to do
something about it we'll do something
about it and i'm curious if you could
explain why
he's saying that the governor should do
something about it rather than the mayor
and if you could also elaborate on what
president trump would be willing to do
well he thinks the mayor and the
governor should work together to take
control of the streets of new york city
where in some places we've seen
600 percent surge in violence over last
year so he thinks they should work
together by the way i hope you guys know
that a lot of this surge in violence
stuff they're attributing to the
defunding and abolishment of police
that hasn't happened in any of these
places and really the reason that
violence is up is people are desperate
the economy when the economy isn't going
well when unemployment is high when
people are earning money are unable to
make their housing payments
32 were unable to do on july 1st
that increases crime and so they're
saying oh look at these dems abolishing
defunding now we've got crime
that hasn't happened what's going on are
crimes of desperation here
governor gavin newsom was one of the few
democratic governors to bring in the
national guard and arm them
after the riots and leaving in early
june as compared to seattle where they
didn't arm the national guard
the guard was posted at los angeles city
hall as a show of force
and within days the violence had well um
why not just invoke the insurrection act
and have a big show of force rather than
these more secretive operations
so i'll leave that to the president um
we don't have secretive operations going
on it's very clear what's going on in
portland it's very clear what's
happening
um in kansas city um but with regard to
the insurrection
act look we believe that it should be
governors and mayors doing what they
have the constitutional power to do the
police power rest with them
um so it's up to this president whether
he ever decides to invoke that but
governors and mayors really need to step
it up particularly in democrat
cities where democrat streets are out of
control and then the one for my
colleague um
john izzy at newsmax is asking what are
the president's
thoughts on john kasich supporting joe
biden and his plans to appear at the
john kasich um is supporting joe biden
and he plans to attend the convention
and support the
beta republican john kasich campaign but
this president's quite proud of his
record in the republican party and quite
proud to have the support of 96 of the
party more than
any predecessor um in the history of the
republicans that's a lie yes
thanks um you said earlier that the
president was tested multiple times a
day
we knew he was tested daily but can you
elaborate on that how many times a day
he's tested often i'm not going to read
out exactly how many times he's tested
today but sometimes it is more than one
time why why not tell him
uh yesterday the president said that
when he was previously doing briefings
we had
a lot of people watching record numbers
watching in the history of cable
television
and i was wondering if ratings are
factoring into his decision to restart
the briefing this president wants to
speak to
the best person to get accurate
information about the virus out to the
public
given previous statements of briefings
like the speculation that disinfectants
inside the human body
could work as a treatment which medical
experts say is not the case
and claims that the virus will just
disappear well the president is the
right person to give information to the
american people he was elected by the
american people
he's been a leader on this um the fact
that we've uh
we've out produced on ventilator so much
so that we have an extraordinary number
in our stockpile and we're giving
ventilators notice that at this point
ventilators is their escape pod any
question that gets at trump's
incompetence
they mentioned ventilators and launched
the escape pod
phase three clinical trial that because
of him we have remdessevier and
convalescent plasma and dexamethasone
and
we don't have those things because of
trump and dexamethasone has been around
who knows how why it's insane
boy does he get the information to a lot
of the american people during his
briefings
imagine claiming that we have
dexamethasone because of trump it's like
saying we have aspirin because of trump
is planning additional seven tariffs
against europe in the old
dispute about aerospace subsidies is the
president committed to impose additional
sanctions
considering that europe would answer
with additional sanctions
tariffs as well so since that's
pre-decisional i won't get ahead of on
any administration announcements on that
front
yes can we have a couple of questions
the first one is the president in las
vegas tweeted about
the concerns about mail-in voting so
he's obviously concerned about the
integrity
of the u.s election and certainly
internal sabotage but why are we not
hearing from the president about spirits
about
external sabotage for example coming out
of the uk today
there's a parliamentary committee report
that says that
russia influenced the scottish
referendum there are questions about
brexit
but we've really not heard the president
put the kremlin on notice with respect
to the u.s
election this president has been tougher
on russia than any president's put the
world on notice that our election
systems must be secure um
this is under this president in 2018 he
articulated the first
particular cyber strategy for the united
states since 2003.
in 2019 he extended the national
emergency declaration on foreign
election interference he routinely
engages with congress on election
security
for participating 26 elections
security specific hearings um he signed
legislation 71 million
this is a question about something now
and she's listing things trump did in
2018.
the obiden the obama biden
administration
who when told of meddling in 2016 did
nothing and in fact susan rice told the
white house cyber team
to stand down and quote knock it off
when they floated
um uh when they flew it out going back
to hillary four years ago questions
about trump doing something right now
daniel has confirmed the stand down
order that's been in office now more
than three years he's trying to do a
walk up
and done now given these fresh concerns
what are we going to hear from the
president what's been done now i just
listed off
three or four things for you and i'm
happy to go through more we can talk
about the 71 million
in legislation on election security uh
we can talk about the 15 million
for election reform activities we can
talk about legislation making more than
805 million available to states
when it comes to mail and voting um i
would point you to the fact that there's
a wall street journal article just out
today and it talks about the dark omen
for november and
oh my god i'm actually starting to
personally hate this woman even though
normally i kind of keep a distance from
this stuff
we still don't know who the winners are
of some of those races and governor
cuomo decided that he would pre-pay
postage for the ballots and what that
meant was that the post office didn't
put a
postage stamp noting the date uh of the
ballot so as they're collecting these
ballots
in for a month as you asked me about
this so i'm going to answer
that's not true it's still stamped when
it's processed ballots with no postmark
date and in fact what they found is 19
of ballots have been rejected in queens
that that's idiotic if you put a stamp
on it if i send somebody a
self-addressed stamped envelope when
they
mail it and it's processed it gets
stamped with the date this is so stupid
she like doesn't seem to know how mail
works
yes on the china vaccine researches yeah
you've gotten two questions which is
more than some of your colleagues
yes thank you
is have been charged with felonies for
waving guns at protesters that
is that her natural hair color is vowing
to dismiss these charges
where does the president stand on this
yeah the president i asked him about
that this morning
and he said it is absolutely absurd what
is happening to the mccloskeys
um he noted that this is an extreme
abuse of power by the prosecutor and
noteworthy that the prosecutor there
have been many cases brought to her
attention of violent rioters that she's
failed to charge but instead
she's charging the individuals who are
defending themselves
from violent protesters you have 300 to
500 protesters who stormed the gates
tore down the gates and trespassed
on their property and you had patricia
mccloskey who said
that they were telling her they were
going to kill them these protesters at
the moment they were
waving their guns to protect themselves
they were going to come in here she said
they were going to burn down the house
they were going to be living in our
house after i was dead and they were
pointing to different rooms of the house
saying
that's going to be my bedroom that's
going to be my living room and i'm going
to be taking a shower in that room
so they were completely within their
right and it's an egregious abuse of
power on the part of the mccloskeys
turning to a different note i just
wanted to highlight some some great work
being done by senior advisor
ivanka trump there are nearly 40 million
boxes that have been put together by the
farmers to families
program a great partnership to help it's
an iran
and yesterday you had ivanka trump
visiting the dc dream center and
personally distributing a number of food
boxes
uh the distribution resulted in 1 000
boxes delivered
um and i think ivanka for the great work
that she has done there
um and finally i just wanted to note
something on kovid
um dr burks is an extraordinary
uh doctor who's considered this country
dedicated to
her time to serving our country as an
army colonel
she served as an ambassador to pepfar
where she spent her life fighting aids
and hiv abroad and it is appalling the
attack that i saw
on her in the new york times based on no
facts oh dr
burks for weeks
of data to our governors so that they
have the best information to make the
best decisions for their people in their
respective states
i've not seen anyone pouring in are they
going to frame this as an attack on
women
as in the attack on her uh was frankly
appalling and egregious in the new york
times
she's gathering her stuff to leave haley
what is the president signing at 12 15.
what a complete and total embarrassment
unbelievable
just stunning stunning stunning can you
imagine
um we have to remove these people in
november
we have to remove these people it's it's
uh it is imperative
it is imperative for uh
you know we can recover from four years
of this
eight eight years is uh i mean she just
she just left it
just everything about this is crazy this
is completely crazy
um so i'm going to be streaming again in
about four hours donald trump is
resuming coronavirus press briefings
later today
so i'm going to be back and then i'm
going to have a
second a third stream later tonight on
twitch only with alexandra botez
training me for my upcoming chess
tournament so if you're watching on
twitch make sure to follow so you'll be
notified of the next stream in a few
hours
if you're watching on youtube make sure
to hit that subscribe button
so you will be uh notified of the next
stream
in a few hours and i will be back with
all of you
very very soon
you